i can't
i don't need to try this
i mean
i'm not i'm past this
[Music]
huh
who who's doing what in the house
we came up through here and somebody
took this hole out
so where's the other car i had no i
didn't see it i just
i pulled over and i was getting ready to
close
so
you
so i must have came through right after
because i've seen you go down
they would have had to hit it as soon as
17 this is going to be a hit skip
maybe this guy right here
clear on a hit 23 or 40.
okay so just so quickly so i can get you
out of here man what all did you see
what happened now um i've seen you drive
past yes and then as i was driving back
or up through here i'd seen the power
lines
and then i seen all this in the road
and i thought maybe they went off in
here and then i called you guys and
i guess you guys don't have a
dispatch for the police department not
us
not us yeah okay all right um
are you the registered owner
yeah yeah okay
17 break for a seven this is just going
to be a witness vehicle
nice
i've seen a guy walking across the two
right
like this is the second time this poll
has been ripped out really
but um i think they're out of their
house if yeah
yeah
but i don't think thankfully anything's
too damaged
with their property
but i think you'll be good to go if you
need a lean man okay but thanks right
there okay what'd you see um okay so i
seen him come through and he lost
control hit this pole yeah he came over
here hit the stop sign lost control and
he spun out over there hit the house
there's babies that live in that house
yeah it scared the hell out of me
because i got babies
so he hit the house and i'm seeing him
trying to get out and he backed his
truck up as you guys were coming up so
he was trying to leave yeah yeah okay
i mean obviously the way he was coming
through and the speed he had
so he was speeding the oh my god yeah
they come through like that all the time
like he ran right through their fence
and everything okay
hi
um
a little thing over here takes out that
stop sign
that drunk how do you even make it there
i i've not even made contact with them
jesse got here first because he almost
tried to leave here but he couldn't get
out of the out of the yard and this
truck was starting to fail
um i was over there because a dude was
who i think someone had stopped
um
so
holy cow
by himself
uh yeah where's he at in becker squad so
they're about to clear him um and then
i'm gonna have to have him shut up
lights because i got so many winky
lights going on right now like it's
gonna be kind of hard to do fields on
him without blinky lights
yeah jesse's gonna have him get
contacted uh
i'm not sure
i'm not sure what kind of lines down i
think it's a telephone pole but because
the tele because uh one of those light
poles got ripped out but there's only
the one line on it so i don't know if
it's actually a
are you on any kind of medication
you don't take no kind of heart
medications nothing like that at all
any medical conditions diabetic or
anything
but your blood sugar was fine do you
treat with insulin or kills or anything
with insulin yes okay you've had all
your insulin and everything today
no not today
okay so your blood sugar was 245 so
that's at a little bit of a high level
but it's not enough that you know
very high
[Music]
is that
right you're in georgetown ohio so it's
like i said it's about 60 miles east of
cincinnati
you just don't know how you got here
17-84 run a kentucky deal
extra's definitely
you don't want to go to the hospital
what we're going to do you've only got
one
[Music]
i'll talk to you guys
i don't know i think the police officers
probably have to talk to you for a
minute but
i assume i don't know after that
they did not agree with the accident
and again
[Music]
is
[Music]
okay
you guys watch the game this evening
i need you to come back to your cruiser
so you can turn your light bar off
why
my name is officer ram i'm with
georgetown
so what happened tonight
i think i fell asleep you fell asleep
okay i had a couple bourbon so i'm not
gonna lie
uh but that's all i have i was doing a
fundraiser for bootsy collins
up in hamilton i live in uh northern
kentucky edgewood kentucky
actually a little bit further south
union in kentucky
i was heading home and
like i said i had i had a couple of
bourbons but that's all i had
but i think i fell asleep because i
how did you get all the way out here
well
i played to the reds
back in the 80s and late 90s or early
90s
and they asked me to do a fundraiser for
him i said i'd love to
[Music]
so i drove out there
i had a couple of bourbons and obviously
it affected me more than i thought i
mean
i think more than more than anything
else i felt asleep okay so is this the
way you took to get over there like
through georgetown
actually i took uh
275
and then took was that 129
maybe
uh maybe the uh
hamilton
i don't i don't remember that that was
at like six o'clock this afternoon okay
i'm just wondering did you mean to come
to georgetown
i don't i was just trying to take the uh
i posted my
uh address to get home and that's where
i was just okay so your gps told you to
come this way okay but i think i fell
asleep you know
okay
um so i i'm not sure what all you talked
my squad about so i gotta ask the same
questions over again do you have any
medical issues
say it again do you have any medical
problems
uh
no i'ma try
to do it
are you on any other types of
medications
are you only any types of opioids
no
no
not at all
okay
are you on any other type of medication
they haven't had insulin in a couple
weeks
okay
do you have any injuries not necessarily
just from the crash but from the crash
or from anything else do you have any
problems with your neck leg backs hips
anything like that
okay are you supposed to wear corrective
lenses i just woke up and i was crashing
and i said oh wow yeah um
do you are you supposed to wear glasses
or contacts
no
okay all right so i'm gonna have you
walk here behind my squad with me so i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna have you do a
couple tests for me right you got it
now i had
okay and i lost my wife about a month
ago
okay
so my hat
all right nice great okay
hey can you turn those off
all right i'm gonna have you stand here
about this squad
all right once they turn off these
blinky lights
i can't have the flashy lights
okay cool
all right
hmm actually i'm gonna have you kind of
stand back here
come to here yeah
all right can you turn around and face
me
well i got flashy lights back there
sorry i'm trying to think of those best
way to make this happen
all right can you look over here for me
yeah boom all right so i want you to put
your feet together here put your hands
up here on your cheeks like this
all right so i want you to follow the
tip of my pen with your eyes and your
eyes only do you understand
all right
are you following that okay
so
let's go
okay this is going to go up
one more
okay you can blink a couple times i have
one more eye test for you what i'm going
to do is i'm going to take my pen and a
couple circles around your face and then
bring my pen into the bridge of your
nose but i'm not going to touch you do
you understand yeah all right same thing
as before hands back up on your cheeks
i'm going to have you follow the tip of
my pen with your eyes and your eyes only
and keep your head still do you
understand no i understand all right see
my pen up here
one more
okay do your knowledge have you ever had
problems crossing your eyes
no
no
no
okay all right
let's see
no
okay
i think this is level
think this is level
i think it looks i think it looks level
to me all right sir i'm gonna have you
come over here and stand here
right where my flashlight beam is
all right so would you agree that the
ground in front of you is level and
straight for your debris i don't know
okay
oh i'll trust you you trust me all right
might not be a good idea
all right so i want you to do is i want
you to imagine a nice straight line in
front of you on that line you're going
to put your left foot put your right
foot ahead of the left with your heel
touching your toe and your hands down at
your side so go ahead and stand like i
am
now let me tell you i only have three
toes here yeah
how about does it affect your balance
i'm okay i'll try okay so i need you to
put your right foot ahead of your left
like this
that way i mean yeah but i need you to
be able to keep him in line like mine
well i i can't guarantee that the left
side just
if i get a little bit uh
i mean i'm not going to lie to you i'm
intoxicated
yeah
all right so can you hold on hold on
hold on hold on cadegas a couple stuck
steps back you're giving your short
yourself up some room all right so are
you going to be able to stand like this
no
no okay
all right
just because i don't have the ability to
all right well i'm going to give you a
balanced test that is problem i
hopefully you're not going to
necessarily
well you don't have to let me explain to
you and you'll tell me if you can do it
okay
all right what i want you to do is once
you put your feet together like this
hands down your sides
all right so when i tell you to begin
you're going to raise one foot whichever
one you want approximately six inches
off the ground and you're going to point
your toe outwards you're going to count
out loud by thousands outward that way
i'll show you i'm going to count out
loud by thousands until i tell you to
stop all right so this is what it's
going to look like
one thousand one one thousand two one
thousand three so and so forth until i
tell you to stop and then go where
you're just gonna stand there
all right so while you're doing this
test i need you to make sure you keep
your eyes on your raised foot and count
out loud do you understand do you want
me to count yep you're going to count
out loud
do you understand that or do you want me
to go through again
because i'm not do do you understand all
those instructions
okay i want to make sure give me one sec
gotta get a timer
all right and again and you want me to
do
one two
keep going
what do you mean
can you keep trying for me or
no i tried to get home because i don't
have anybody i mean
okay
so what do you want me to do
all right well we're gonna go ahead and
stop that one
all right
okay so this last one is super easy okay
all right all i need you to do is put
your feet together hands down your sides
now i'm gonna have you do is i'm gonna
have you tilt your head back towards the
sky so your nose is pointed upward and
you're gonna close your eyes when you
believe that 30 seconds has passed hold
on hold on hold on when you believe that
30 seconds has passed you're going to
tilt your head back forward
open your eyes and say stop
do you understand
you want me to
lift my head up
and then absolutely how long
so i'm going to have you tilt your head
up close your eyes and when you believe
that 30 seconds has passed you're going
to tilt your head back open your eyes
and say stop
do you understand i do all right give me
one sec got to get timer going again all
right and begin
all right
all right and how did you get to that
number
can you demonstrate how you counted for
me 1001 0002
about that speed
yeah okay
honey i'm intoxicated i know i am all
right go ahead and turn turn around put
your hands behind your back
all right sir so you are under arrest
for operating a vehicle and d influence
are those too tight
okay at any point they get like that
maybe need to check them just let me
know okay
all right i'm gonna have you come with
me so the car that's in front of the at
the squad here we're gonna go to that
one all right
have you ever been arrested for this
before
no okay
no i was i probably shouldn't have been
here for this one
all right we're gonna go to the other
side the passenger side
is there anything on you that you know
about that might stick me hurt me poke
me anything like that
no but i have a
marijuana pipe okay where is that that's
in my left pocket okay i have one um
okay i mean i haven't tested since
this morning so okay all right i'm gonna
search real quick
i have a little zipper on my uh right
down here on the left side yep
yep that's it okay you have a little
packet there oh a little
whatever it is
i'll i'll check it in here in a second
all right put that in your pocket
because i don't want to lose any of
what's in there there's nothing in there
the cell phone
sir yes sir i got your cell phone out of
the truck it's in your pocket all right
okay you got it okay
all right thank you
all right i'm gonna have you pop in here
did they turn that car off and uh
i have your keys and the car's off all
right all right
[Music]
i can't go left too much okay